let me read this next story which is a
little creepy folks
brace for impact this is not fake news
this is a real story democrats want to
monitor your text
and use aggressive fact checkers to
dispel vaccine misinformation reports
claims this is the daily mail story the
biden administration is planning to ramp
up efforts to combat vaccine
misinformation in areas where
vaccination rates are lagging and
coveted cases are rising according to
reports
the dnc is considering working with sms
companies to vet
tax tax and send messages directly to
americans to stop the spread of
inaccurate information the party
organization is also reportedly
considering employing aggressive fact
checkers
to monitor communication in a planning
of drawn furious pushback from
conservatives the biden administration
officials are now looking at the next
step as 91 million people remain
unvaccinated and 43 states are seeing an
increase in covet infections
in the last week as data variants delta
variance causes
cases to spike
aggressive fact checkers i mean could
there be a more scary phrase out there
i mean i don't know it's it's one of
those stories that seems made up i have
some notes i'm going to find them here
in one second
you know i thought i spent four years
being told by every liberal that i know
that donald trump was this outrageous
dictator yet
they absolutely have lost their voice
when it comes to joe biden wanting to
read our text our emails and sending
people door to door
to stab us with some mixed some mystery
juice i i i don't
uh i i'd love for them to find their
their uh their fear of of autocratic
tyranny again i you know this this idea
that we were living
on on the brink of fascism but you know
they're reading your texts for your own
good don't worry about it these people
are nuts man you know who's driving this
because if joe biden was president say
when clinton was president
if he became president in 1992 he
wouldn't be doing this stuff right i
don't think i don't know how many
original thoughts
joe biden has right now any real vision
where is it coming from
yeah is there a group is there one
person is it two is it five is it the
radicals is it
i don't know man i i don't know you know
but the the
way that they just outright lie also now
with no consequence
you know i said it the last time i was
on the podcast but i
i only can hear every time i hear jen
sackey talk
i just hear alexander slosnich from the
the gulag archipelago
we know that they're lying they know
that we know that they're lying we know
that they know
that we know that they're lying and yet
they still lie she says on one day
we're telling facebook we are helping
facebook flag
uh dangerously misinformed posts
and then the next day she goes we're not
having any posts taken down what are you
talking about
where'd you get that information two
days back to back she made those claims
and it's like
my god what what this is coming from the
white house
the white house is saying we're working
with a private company to
censor information that we don't like
and then the next day she just flat out
denies that they're doing it
to the press and the press don't push
her on it i don't understand what's
happening
by the way politico wrote this article
originally
usa today responded saying the fact that
this is not a true story but they're not
saying that it's not
a true story they're saying it's a
fact check biden doesn't want to monitor
private texts for vaccine
uh misinformation this is a usa today's
story biden wants phone companies to
monitor the people text for vaccination
the claim
and they're answering it that it's not
now i'm going to put the story below
if you can pull the story up already
based on the recent claim but inform one
comes to monitor people's
vaccines so usa today type in usa today
sms text go to it and i'll
read the story at the end i think noted
if we all attracted every other
sms text biden just put sms text biden
and uh let me see if it comes of
actually okay go to that one and go all
the way to the bottom let's read it
together
can you make the screen bigger so the
audience can see this rather than seeing
us
okay so if you go to the story all the
way in the bottom keep going keep going
keep going okay a little bit higher a
little bit higher right there
okay you know a little higher a little
higher okay our ratings falls
our rating falls based on our research
the claim that byte wants phone
companies monitor the people six were
accumulating false this is a
misinterpretation of a
kai what are you doing kai
this is a mystery this is a
misinterpretation of
kai just stop doing what you're doing
buddy oh my gosh don't touch the
computer
this is a misinterpretation of dnc's
effort to report this information
uh a spokesperson from the dnc said it
has no ability to monitor private text
messages and said that the nccr's
instance is a possible term of use of
violation reported by the public
to the sms api companies the biden
administration is not involved
i don't know how that means fact by the
way go a little higher to read the dates
uh what does that say on the bottom no
the other way the other way go uh
okay got it so i look i don't know if
it's saying if it's not or it is
so basically trust me bro yeah that's
exactly what that sounded like
that's what that sounded it's a trial
balloon how much outrage is there going
to be because if it's not too big then
we'll actually do it
here's a question for you guys here's a
question for you what's such a big deal
what's such a big deal if they check
your text huh hear me out
they're if they're all you don't think
they're checking stuff on social you
don't think they're checking stuff on
facebook
you don't think they're checking stuff
on twitter you don't think they're
checking stuff on youtube what's next
next is text why are you surprised
if they're trying to impose to do that
why are you surprised i'm not saying
support it and do it but why are you
surprised that they would try to reach
to go to text
just because it's a one-on-one
communication and you would anticipate
it'd be a little bit more private
what is dm what is facebook there's one
thing that you publish and there's a
then another thing that that's private
imagine if like every draft
your first draft went public you know
what i'm saying like
that's you there's what you put out into
the world
i'm not surprised though i'm not saying
you should be surprised it doesn't make
it doesn't make it right
i never said it makes it i never said it
make sure so we should push back on
things that are wrong shouldn't we have
a hundred
percent 100 100 but
i'm not surprised that they're trying to
go there next do you have
do you have fear or anxiety at all about
the you know how they're starting to say
the loud the quiet parts out loud
how the surveillance you know state is
basically being exposed and that
you know we are we are a proxy to our
you whether whether you want to believe
it's the nsa the cia
the uh the homeland security i mean
they're really running the ship here you
really believe they're not tracking
stuff
of course they are so but now they're
doing it publicly no no i get that you
really believe that they're saying we're
not doing that
snowden talked about this how many years
ago yeah so
you don't think that certain words are
being followed like we have an sms
system right that we send messages at
we have the ability to have you text a
word
that sends a any report back to you a
pdf back to you it's automated
and we send a pdf back to you you don't
think they have the technology to look
at 20 key words
to see what that conversation sounds
like the patriot act is such an
abomination
it stands against everything about it
with giuliani it's it's an abomination
and he he was a proponent of it and now
he's a critic of it
it's it's no fun when the rabbits got it
right but if you are
if you're well right now you're an
american citizen you're
maybe the most pro-american guy i've
ever met if you have a third cousin
in iran or from or or in syria
and they're doing something nefarious
somebody that you've never met in your
life
you are now exposed to the fisa courts
they can they can tap you they can have
warrantless wiretaps on you because
you're two steps away from from a target
that's that's
asinine man we we have to have some
semblance of privacy and privacy is
freedom right like we can't
we can't just allow these guys to be in
our lives at all times especially if
it's ai flagging us
right can we i mean am i the only other
no i'm with you a hundred percent
we're on the same yeah i have a question
for you guys if i may
so earlier we spoke please don't please
don't raise your voice
just to have more power over us lower
your audio ten percent instead of
screaming at us the way you just did
like
go ahead voice of god so uh so we spoke
about how important
by the way why don't you do the first
three lines of your song go ahead do it
okay no dude so do the first three can't
do it right
do two of them no right now i need the
guitar go grab it
no no i'm just not quite you're not
gonna ask the question if you're gonna
do that go get the guitar for him kyle
you go do that
he's gonna do it live three i got 20
minutes no no no go grab
i'm telling you go grab the guitar we'll
do it for the next no no we're not doing
that go grab the guitar
go grab the guitar and then you can ask
your question i want to know your
questions you know what i forgot about
we're not working that this environment
is a pressure type of environment go get
it all right let's go let's
raise my voice and now no no no can you
see this getting
pulled back at all or are we too far to
the edge do you see
the world ever are we just gonna have to
become
cognizant of no we're not it's not going
to be people we're not wired that way
look
we are wired to be able to sin
and choose not to sin we are not
wired to be robots none of us we are
wired to make mistakes
whenever in a relationship in a
parent relationship in a marriage in a
friendship in a work environment
it gets to the point where you're
walking on eggshells
it creates such an environment of
anxiety and panic that people start
doing
crazy stuff you cannot do that long term
it is not a sustainable model
history has proven when you do this for
too long people eventually snap
and it's not a pretty snap when they do
so it's not going to be a pretty thing
for them long term you cannot
you cannot mess with this part i have to
have the freedom to sin
my kids if i tell them don't do it
here's how my daughter is okay
i'll say i'm not even kidding with you
here's your wiring
i'll say sena don't touch
the what do you call it the uh the
remote control no no the
the whatever it's not slinky the slimy
stuff
i'm like senna put the slime ball down
she goes like this
stop kicking your brother he has to do
it one more time
he just kicks him one more time dylan
stop hitting my back
he just taps it one more time i mean
we're like that yeah that's just like
you know so what are you gonna do if you
tell them don't do that i mean they're
gonna do it so
we don't change from being kids so the
game plan for me is the following
i'm gonna treat you so good i'm going to
be respectful to you i'm going to bring
value to you
that you want me in your life i'm going
to treat you so well that you won't you
want to stay my client for a long time
i'm going to take care of you that you
want to stay with me as an audience i'm
going to be
that's the only way when you do it this
way history doesn't favor people like
this
yep plenty of examples by the way this
does not mean america cannot lose
everything it has i didn't say that
i never said that this let me let me
straighten that part out this doesn't
mean america cannot lose
all its freedom it has this doesn't mean
that
this only means that if america does
another america is going to pop up
that's what this means
i interviewed the guy from 2034. what is
him elliot akerman i think his name is
elliot ackerman the guy's got a purple
heart silver
he's got everything right he said
history tells us
that empires tend to self-destruct at
years where are we at right now oh god
where we are right now
you know what we're 49 no just do the
math 1776 plus 250 45 240. there you go
give or take so 1776
is what plus uh uh what what is that 244
245 245 we got five more years to go
self-destruct he says that
empire's at 250 self-destruct we're
still a baby
so if you enjoyed this little segment
from the podcast click over here to
watch the entire podcast and if you've
not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]